I think it might be cool to see kind of like
another story featuring an evil devil goat,
or just this devil goat wandering the countryside.
Or how this goat came to be the devil.
So the whole movie is just an evil goat?
Yeah!
You're describing Goat Simulator right now.
I am.
Yeah.
Well, there you go.
Hi!
Today we're talking about horror villain origin
stories that we want to see on screen.
And yeah, this is a tough one for a lot of
reasons.
Because part of what makes a horror movie
villain so good sometimes, is not knowing
sort of what makes them who and what they
are.
And a lot of times kind of like giving some
information, too much backstory, can kind
of let a lot of the air out of the balloon,
and kind of take the mystery and the menace
and the scary stuff away.
Do you guys agree when I say this thing?
Yes.
Hundred percent.
Yeah.
Because I mean, we've talked about this on
the show before, the prequel curse, right?
I mean, sometimes it really works, and then
other times you're like, "I didn't want to
know that stuff."
Yeah.
And I don't care how Han Solo got his jacket.
Right, right, right.
I don't care how Wolverine got his jacket.
Right.
And mystery in a horror movie is so important.
Yeah.
I don't care how anyone got their jackets.
I don't care how Black Widow got her jacket.
Wow.
It's a lot of jacket-related origin stories
now that I think about it.
Yeah.
I never thought about it until just now.
Prequels are very sartorial.
I will say jackets are expensive.
I mean it makes sense that there would be
a lot of drama behind getting a new one.
Yeah.
How did Loki get his hat?
That's what I want to know.
Nobody knows that.
Now there's a question.
But there's a scene, there a-
Yeah.
But, I do imagine he had one of those banana
seat bicycles, and then he crashed it so hard
that his head kind of just ... The handlebar
stuck.
Aw.
There's a few on here that are interesting
to think about on this list on Looper.com,
the few that I responded to.
Because I'm not a big horror guy, but I've
seen a few.
The facility from the Cabin in the Woods,
that could be interesting.
That could be fun kind of picture show.
I actually did like that one.
Cabin in the Woods scared the living daylights
out of me.
I didn't sleep for like a week.
That's a good movie.
I'm a baby.
I'm sorry.
I should get that out of the way.
I'm a huge horror baby.
It's a comedy horror movie for children.
No, here's the thing though.
I was okay with Cabin in the Woods until ... I
think the thing that broke me was the ballerina
with the teeth of face, or the face of teeth.
Oo, it was a good one.
Yeah.
I think that really, that stuck in my brain,
and it ruined me for a little while.
I was okay with a lot of it.
And then the monster explosion at the end,
I was like, "I don't like this."
Yeah.
That's really fair.
Because sometimes all it takes is one image.
Yeah.
One disturbing thing to set you off.
A thing I really don't like is body horror.
I don't like when things move weirdly or incorrectly,
that really frightens me.
So yeah, body horror too much, I can't do
it.
I felt that way when I saw The Ring in theaters,
and that one got ... That stuck in my brain
for a while.
And it's just, it's again, it's all that just
disturbing imagery.
I sleep with a TV in my room.
I could never watch The Ring ever, because
I have a television in my room and I would
just never sleep again.
Maybe it would break you of having a TV in
your room.
Whatever.
It's such a habit, you don't want to.
Scientists don't know me.
You don't care.
So anyway, Cabin in the Woods would be an
interesting one, because maybe ... I can even
envision it sort of like a rotating, a TV
series, a prequel series.
It's just those two guys.
Just going about their day job and scaring
people, killing people, sacrificing to the
great God, whatever the plot turned out to
be.
Spoilers for Cabin in the Woods.
Spoilers for all these movies, I'm sorry.
We're going to put a list of all the movies
that we're going to talk about now after Cabin
in the Woods right here.
Okay.
So if you don't want those movies spoiled,
potentially, you can click away now.
By the way leave a like.
Thank you very much.
So, other movies on this list, Nina, I know
you've seen The Orphan or Orphan as it's called.
A long time ago.
It's more of a thriller than a horror.
A few of the ones on the list are more thriller
style, which is something that I really like.
I like the thrill of ... to be scared by tension
rather than, "Boo!"
It's a scary ghost thing, which I think is
what The Conjuring is.
You're favorite genre.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Boo!
Oo, it's a scary ghost thing.
Thank you.
So Orphan has one of the most bonkers twists
in movie history where these people adopt
a very weird child, and she's being very weird
and violent and murdery, turns out that she
is an adult who is a disease that makes her
look like a little kid.
And she also engaged in a career that one
would not want a child to be in.
I don't know how to say this in this video
without getting flagged.
Acting?
Kind of.
In a fashion.
So, you can look it up.
Just go look it up.
It's pretty weird.
It's pretty messed up.
And so it turns out that's she just-
A grown up party facilitator.
Yeah, great.
Perfect.
And it turns out she's like-
Hate it.
... just been trying to ... They just have
this 33 year old kid in their house, who's
trying to murder them.
And I just love ... You know what?
Go for it, right?
If you're going to have a twist, make it as
weird as possible.
Swing hard and we'll see how it goes.
It didn't go great.
But, I respect the ambition.
So would origin story ...
It would be about her, right?
Yeah.
Because I think they adopt her from ... Oh
my God.
I don't know what country just put it below
me now.
I don't remember where.
But yeah.
I haven't seen that movie since it came out.
Yeah, I guess it would be about her.
I think that actually would probably be fine,
except you'd have to get the original actress
or someone who looks exactly like her.
I don't know how that would work.
I don't know.
Tough sell.
That actually feels like something that they
would make considering ... Didn't they do
an Annabelle prequel or spinoff from "The
Conjuring" film?
Yeah.
So this doesn't feel that out of the realm
of possibility, to be honest.
It could happen.
It could work.
Mm-hmm.
It would ruin the twist of the movie though,
of the actual movie that it spawned from.
Right.
But I mean, I think-
Don't most horror sequels, though?
Yeah.
But this is an origin story.
It's a prequel.
I don't know.
At this point, all I'm thinking of is how
dumb is this idea?
And you can tell me right now.
Should a sequel to Orphan be called, Morphin?
Yes.
First off, it's not dumb.
"Here's a bag of cash.
Go write it"
Not dumb at all.
I think you hit the nail right on the head.
Thank you.
I think you scratched the itch that society
didn't know it had.
Wait, wouldn't a prequel to "Orphan" be called
"I Have Parents"?
Well sure.
I was saying ...
A good prequel, yeah.
Yeah.
Yes.
Parents.
Parents would be better.
Just call it Parents.
Awful Parents.
It's just five minutes of someone being dropped
off at an orphanage.
That's the whole movie.
Other ones on here ... Again, and I'm just
going to kind of scratch the surface for a
few more of these.
Like Red from Us.
It's an interesting idea.
I liked a lot of Us until the end explanation
where it kind of goes into the world building
that created this situation, these doubles.
And, that's where it lost me.
So I feel like, while I would be interested
to see how they could make it work, I also
inherently don't think the premise, the underlying
world of Us worked that well for me.
So I'll say that I'd want to see an origin
story for Red from Us, if for no other reason
than to give that film a chance to kind of
redeem where it lost me in the first one.
Mm-hmm.
And then the only other one on here that I
kind of want to dive into a little bit more,
is the Overlook Hotel from The Shining, which
I thought was a really interesting idea.
Yeah, I don't know.
The creepy hotel that makes people nuts in
The Shining, what's that place's story.
That's an origin story that I think would
not necessarily take away from the power that
it has in The Shining.
And I think that you could, again, you could
set it as a series.
Make it this really interesting, terrifying,
creepy place that terrifying, creepy things
happen.
I don't know.
I don't ... Yeah.
Well and, maybe at the very end of it, Grady
shows up.
The movie ends when he arrives, the guy who
... That's the guy who kills his family before
the ... Torrances right?
Grady?
I don't remember.
Guys, come on.
Sorry.
No, but I mean like, because that's when-
Technically it's my day off.
I don't remember anything after-
No, but when Jack and his family show up at The
Overlook at first, the proprietor, whose name
I definitely don't remember, is like, "Oh
yeah, the last family who stayed here, the
husband went crazy and he killed his family.
Anyway, here are the keys have fun."
And it's very weird that he tells him that.
And so I'm imagining a cool sequel would be
like, how The Overlook kind of gets its ... How
it came to be so haunted.
But then the last shot is the previous Jack
Torrance showing up-
Sure.
... with his twin daughters.
Those are the daughters that he-
Oh!
... he kills.
Yeah.
And his giant elevator full of blood.
Mm-hmm.
He pulls that up behind him.
Oh did he now?
He's finally in the dog costume.
He found room for it in the U-Haul.
He could bring it with him.
It's fine!
"It's just a U-Haul filled with blood.
It's a little trailer."
Exactly.
"Don't open that up!"
Yeah.
"Be careful!"
"Get the buckets!"
"Get the siphon!"
So one that I thought that might be interesting
... And again, I'm not a big horror guy.
So I apologize right off the top that I'm
starting this video off with just being like,
"I don't know what I'm talking about," which
is fine.
Because what's the difference?
Black Philip from The Witch.
Are you familiar with The Witch?
Either of you?
Didn't see The Witch.
I'm so sorry.
So, The Witch is a-
I think that's probably way above my horror
pay grade in terms of being scary.
Fill me in, Brian.
It's not even ... Again, that's more of a
tension kind of thing.
Oh, okay.
It's not really gory at all.
Then I might watch it, yeah.
But it's like, mounting dread.
Oo, yeah.
But I'm going to spoil it.
Okay.
I've probably read the Wikipedia entry, it's
fine.
Black Philip is the goat that is on their
farm that the two creepy little kids in the
family, they sing songs about.
And they're like, "We're talking to Black
Philip.
Black Philip is, he's going to get you," or
whatever.
It turns out that Black Philip is in fact
an embodiment of the devil.
Oh.
And eventually seduces our lead character
into witchcraft.
Which is on Taylor-Joy's debut.
Right?
So that move gave us-
Yeah.
And she's amazing in it.
She's amazing in everything.
Yeah.
She's so good.
So, but yeah.
I don't know.
I think it might be cool to see kind of another
story featuring an evil devil goat.
Or just this devil goat wandering the countryside,
or how this goat came to be the devil.
The whole movie is just an evil goat.
You're describing Goat Simulator right now.
I am!
Yeah.
Well, there you go.
I actually, I love Goat Simulator as a prequel
to that.
I want to see the Babadook's origin story
for that same reason.
Because I want to see how the Babadook became
a queer icon.
Dude, cool.
Yeah.
Moves to a big city, gets wrapped up in like
a lot of scene stuff that he's not ready for.
Yeah.
He goes to his first Pride parade.
He's like, "Wow.
I love this whole atmosphere."
He just this small town Babadook.
He's going to go from Babadork to Babadook.
That's the tagline, right?
Oh, God that rocks.
That is terrific.
Yeah.
Rodney Dangerfield as the Babadook.
He's another bag of cash.
I have all the spoilers today.
Perfect.
But Tom, what do you think?
What are some horror villain origin stories
that you'd like to see?
Brian, I'm really glad that you brought up
The Orphan earlier because-
It's just Orphan.
The character from the ... I apologize.
You're right.
That's breezier.
Thank you, Zuckerberg.
That's terrific.
Drop the "The."
It's cleaner.
I'm glad that you brought it up.
The villain from that is actually really similar
to one of my favorite horror villains of all
time.
Another seemingly innocent, kind of quirky
female presence that gets brought into this
familial setting, and it turns out that the
whole thing is this lie and that ... Lucy
from While You Were Sleeping.
I would love to find out why it is that she's
alone at the holidays.
What happened to her family?
Apparently her whole family died.
How'd that happen?
I like While You Were Sleeping.
I like this movie.
I did too.
I think it's a really effective piece of horror.
I think that it's a terrifying proposition.
No, I agree with what you were saying earlier.
I think that most of the time, horror characters
are either mysterious, like spooky, or they're
metaphors.
And that explaining more about either of those
things doesn't make them more scary, or more
effective.
The Cabin in the Woods, the facility is a
metaphor for horror movies, right?
That's the idea?
Yes.
I don't know.
I love the idea of an anthology series where
we explore this place.
But overall, getting more explanations, that
doesn't make it a more effective scary thing.
Right?
Right.
I'm rambling.
Please continue.
That's okay.
That's all this is.
Cool.
Yeah.
We have fun.
Nina.
Now that Tom has effectively trolled me and
my enjoyment of a classic Sandra Bullock romantic
comedy-
Mm-hmm.
That was great.
I thought he was going to steal my pick.
So I'm very-
Well what's your pick?
Now that we-
I would never steal your pick.
I was so sure.
Because you were describing a seemingly innocent
woman drawn into a familial situation, only
to reveal that she is sinister and I ... Okay.
I want to preface this by saying that I don't
actually necessarily want this movie idea
to happen.
I'm just saying if it got green-lit, I probably
would go see it.
So one of my favorite movies, not just horror
movies, but like any movie is Get Out.
I love Get Out very, very much.
Sure.
I saw it in theaters, I've probably watched
upwards of 500 times.
It's just, it's perfect.
It's such a good movie from beginning to end.
It's a really, really good movie.
And I don't don't want a prequel to it.
But if it had to happen, I would want it to
go all the way back to when the Armitage family
started doing this.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
I don't want the prequel to be about Rose.
I don't want it to be Rose hunts for men to
steal.
Or people, rather.
But I want to go back to the grandparents,
and why this even came into their minds.
If I am going to see a villain origin story
from a horror movie that I love, and it had
to happen, I think that would be the only
kind of thing I could handle.
Again, I don't ... Like we've talked about
with so many of these, it would take away
so much of the cool stuff in Get Out.
Right.
And it would also prevent Daniel Coulier from
being involved, or Allison Williams, or any
of the phenomenal cast members.
But, if somebody was going to capitalize off
of Get Out's success, that's the only way
I can see it even vaguely working.
So that's my submission.
That could be neat.
Do you know what I would call a prequel, an
origin story, to Get Out?
"Come In"?
Yeah.
Parents.
That's it.
I'm dumb.
I don't have any good ideas.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
And old.
Brian, you have no good car ideas.
None of us have any good car ideas.
"And old."
Yeah.
I don't know.
Horror movies.
I mean, again, the one that I keep going back
to is ... Because it's one of the only horror
movies that I've actually watched, is The
Thing.
But do I want to see an origin story of this
horrible alien demon?
Not really.
I'm curious, but I don't know.
Probably not a ton of story to tell.
Right?
Yeah.
It's a ball of goo, and it likes pizza.
Alien comes to Earth.
Why did it leave?
Right.
I don't know.
Is it the hero of ... I don't know.
It had religious differences with its parents.
It's a difficult one.
How did it get its jacket?
How did The Thing get its jacket?
Thanks for watching.
Please hit like and subscribe.